[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily famed private eye
jack bellandino
dies from injuries during an attempted
robbery how police say he helped catch
his own killers
for anybody who thinks that they can
attack elderly individuals in our city
you need to think twice a key suspect
appears to be flipping in the missing
connecticut mom case
but prosecutors admit evidence in
jennifer dolos's murder
is still largely circumstantial she
basically lies through her teeth
one of r kelly's associates pleads
guilty to paying off an accuser
what this could mean for the disgraced r
b singer's own trial
a botched murder for hire plot
apparently takes out the wrong people
why a louisiana mother is being credited
with pretending to be a rape victim
to save her daughter's life they were
asking for the victim
and she said she said
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a legendary private investigator to the
stars killed in san francisco
helped solve his own murder law and
crimes angenette levy is here to tell us
more
about how jack paladino collected key
evidence in his own death
yeah brian the two men facing charges in
this case they are
taijo and flournoy and lawrence thomas
and they are being held without bail in
san francisco
the d.a there says that he's waiting for
an official finding from the medical
examiner on cause of death
before upgrading the charges for both of
them to murder
mr palladino was a san francisco legend
someone who dedicated his career to
pursuing justice and truth
san francisco district attorney chasa
bodine vowing justice for jack palladino
palladino was a private eye for
president bill clinton during the
jennifer flowers scandal
he worked for robin williams and
courtney love palladino also
investigated the jonestown massacre
and patty hearst hired him to
investigate her kidnapping
he also looked into the background of a
prosecution witness
in one of our kelly's criminal cases he
was a
consummate rocking tour and a great
character a dear dear friend
and i'll mourn his loss the rest of my
life friends of palladino
say he always had a camera and last week
was no different when he saw something
strange
outside of his home witnesses on the
scene reported seeing a suspect in the
passenger side of a vehicle
in a physical struggle over mr
palladino's camera
during the struggle the vehicle sped
away causing mr paladino to fall to the
ground
palladino suffered a head injury that
took his life
he had taken photos of what he had found
suspicious
here mr palladino an investigator to the
very last day of his life to the very
last
act of his life took photos
that helped confirm police work
identifying
the two assailants in this case
jack palladino was actually the second
elderly person killed in an attack in
san francisco in the last week
the two men facing charges in his death
will be back in court next week
at that time they would both enter pleas
to the charges brian
thanks anjanet joining me today is new
york city public defender anna carlson
and terry austin terry the defendants
are being charged with attempted
uh robbery what is the d.a waiting for
to hear
from the m.e before filing these murder
charges
well brian the d.a wants to see the
medical examiner's report because it's
going to provide
detailed evidence about the cause and
the manner of death so
the cause of death would be something
like falling and hitting his head
or maybe it could be something like a
heart attack and we will hear about that
but the manner is going to tell us
whether or not the emmy thinks it was
murder suicide accident natural causes
or
unknown and i think that is going to
definitely help
the d.a determine whether or not they
can bring
a charge of murder against you know
these individuals
now on a safe bet that it's going to be
a murder charge coming but what do you
expect that murder charge will look like
premeditated reckless or negligent or
maybe felony murder and why
i would absolutely guess felony murder
in this case i think it's
it's sounding like this was maybe a
robbery that they were
that they they didn't plan to come after
him
you know because of who he was but
rather because of equipment
so if if there is a death in the course
of another felony
that would be what we call felony murder
unfortunately
for the people charged they could be
just as liable for the murder
even if they didn't intend for any
injury to occur makes sense now anjanet
there are a lot of questions floating
around particularly about the men being
charged in paladino's death
being suspects in another murder and
asking
why if anything he was still on the
streets right
yeah that's right brian tyjen flournoy
was actually named a suspect in another
murder
last year he was not charged in that
case two other men were and the d.a said
there just simply wasn't enough evidence
to charge him
and another man who was also seen in the
area at the time
but the case remains under investigation
fornoy
when this attack happened last week was
actually on probation for a misdemeanor
gun charge so his probation on that
charge has
also been revoked while he deals with
this other case as well
yes he's probably going to be in on
probation and also facing these charges
these two are definitely have a lot of
criminal cases and woes ahead of them
thank you all for contributing two
federal agents are
dead and three are wounded after serving
a warrant in a crimes against children
case
the fbi says agents arrived to search an
apartment in sunrise florida on tuesday
morning
the suspect who is not yet named is
believed to have opened fire and then
shot and killed himself the agents
reportedly were executing a warrant to
gather evidence
including the suspect's computer for a
child pornography case
agents laura swashenburg and daniel
aflin died from their injuries
the shootout was one of the deadliest
days in the fbi's history
fallen capital police officer brian
siknik is receiving a distinct tribute
laying in honor in the capitol rotunda
sikhnik died last month
from injuries sustained during the riot
at the capitol building
following her ceremony by lawmakers
siknik's remains will be taken to
arlington national cemetery
he's the third capitol police officer to
lay in honor in the rotunda the pitching
coach for the los
angeles angels has been suspended after
five women allege
sexual misconduct five women are
accusing mickey callaway
of lewd behavior in an interview with
the athletic according to the report
the women say callaway sent them
shirtless photos requested nude pictures
and in one instance thrusted his crotch
in a reporter's face
the alleged behavior spans five years
and his employment with three different
organizations
callaway responded to the claim stating
any relationship in which i engage
has been consensual still ahead on law
and crime
daily one of r kelly's associates admits
to paying off witnesses on the singer's
behalf
but first one of the defendants accused
in the disappearance of a mother of five
reportedly is ready to testify against
another defendant
the evidence prosecutors have and don't
have in the jennifer doulos case
next
[Music]
it appears one of the friends of a
deceased husband
accused in his wife's disappearance is
ready to testify against the husband's
mistress
jennifer doulos was reported missing in
may 2019
after dropping her kids off in
connecticut police became suspicious and
then arrested her husband
photos dullos along with his girlfriend
michelle traconis and friend kent mohini
photos dulos died last january of an
apparent suicide
troconus and mohani have each pled not
guilty to conspiracy to commit murder
trochonus is also facing charges of
evidence tampering
prosecutors say they intend to call
mahini at trochonis trial
much of this case is going to be proven
by circumstantial evidence uh
uh mr conus interviews with the state
police i think are
are very telling not in what she
directly says but what she doesn't say
she basically lies through her teeth
about where she was where mr dulos was
what she was doing on certain dates
the statements she gives track along her
alibi script almost
exactly so this argument that the
scripts themselves are are just these
innocent productions that her attorney
uh asked her to write they turned out to
be lies she admitted
in the interviews that they were lied
she said yes this is not true
what we wrote down here and what i said
to you tony cummings
is the state intending to call mr
mahwini as a witness
uh as of now yes i believe so obviously
that could change the uh council's
claiming that this is the state's star
witness i i think castle has strawman
much of what the state has said uh in
this argument and in others um we don't
have a star witness
attorney mcwinney's statement is one
piece out of many pieces
pointing to the defendant's guilt in
this case that the state mayor
put on at trial prosecutors are seeking
to have three cases against draconis
joined together
a motion her defense is objecting to
when mr cummings says my client was
lying
i'd have to respond by saying but you
read you watch those videos and if the
court has seen them
and detectives the detectives lie
through their teeth to my
client and then tell her we know
that there were and this is why i
brought it up those were body parts
in those garbage bags they say that to
her
she starts crying hysterically so they
lied a million times and then
said oh she changed her story because
they said it would be not possible not
to know what was in those bags
so i don't want to get into a
credibility fight with mr cummings or mr
colangelo or for that matter
the police detectives in this case
there's a missing person
they want to solve that i get that
however
i submit that when the court decides on
consolidating cases
particularly when they belong in another
jurisdiction
the state has a burden not to say well
we got all this stuff
but to specifically say here is what we
intend to offer
which is cross-administable i don't have
to guess on that nor does the court
have to guess about that
back to break down the latest chapter of
the tragic dulo saga
is public defender honor carlson and
co-host terry austin
terry mahini is claiming draconis and
doulos try to i guess
solicit him into a conspiracy to do away
with jennifer doulos
does that ring true to you or sound like
a ploy for leniency
it definitely sounds like a ploy you
have to wonder why this was not his
position
when it first occurred back in january
2020 when he was arrested
you know his original story was that he
didn't remember
what happened on the day jennifer
disappeared he was actually
at the house for a meeting on that
fateful day
and he claimed that he fell and he
didn't remember what happened now all of
a sudden
he's you know saying that he was being
solicited to
do away with jennifer and he had nothing
to do with it there's a real
question of credibility here brian and i
think that draconis's attorney is going
to try to say
that mahini's story is made up because
he is
actually trying to get a favorable
treatment
from you know cooperating with
investigators
definitely a possible argument anna it
got a little heated during the uh
the hearing discovery was a big point
the defense wanted the evidence quote
unquote explained
and the prosecutor said they don't have
to again
hold hands through the evidence so who's
right here
well i think it's a split down the
middle and it's going to be entirely
up to the judge i think um one place
where it's likely they will get a little
bit more of a road
map is something that i see all the time
with phone calls
often in my cases i'll have hundreds of
hours of phone calls and this is a case
uh conspiracy case so i would expect
they may have even some calls from the
10 months that mawini was in jail
that they're trying to introduce i would
guess that they'll be able to get
a little bit of a road map if they're
sorting through
hundreds of hours of calls to try to cut
down which of these calls are we saying
could be specific um but
other than that you know the evidence in
these cases i think
the defense should assume that he should
review everything very carefully
exactly thank you both coming up on law
on crime daily
federal prosecutors charge university
officials with hiding their work with
china
plus singer r kelly's legal battles
continue to build
as one of his co-defendants pleads
guilty in court these cases and more
next
one of the associates of disgrace r b
singer r kelly has admitted to trying to
pay off an accuser
in r kelly's case skeeters in brooklyn
say r kelly filmed himself having sex
with underage girls and intimidated
potential witnesses
investigators reportedly wiretapped his
associates and overheard richard arlen
jr
offering the accuser hundreds of
thousands of dollars to not cooperate
with authorities
according to court documents arlen said
the singer was going to pay her to be
quiet
because she had too much information r
kelly's defense attorney steve greenberg
told the law and crime network
that his client is not guilty uh
obviously the law of averages is going
to catch up with us at some point
but you know it's it's this sort of
buyer's remorse
in many of these cases with many of
these allegations
these were people that were ecstatic to
be with
r kelly they were happy to be with our
kelly and now someone else has said to
them
oh no it was no good times have changed
and and in hindsight they're sort of
repurposing the encounters
here to break down the r b the rape and
bribery of r kelly's case
are attorneys terry austin and anna
carlson terry
trying to bribe a witness is a serious
crime what penalties
could richard arlen face you know it's a
very serious crime and under new york
law he faces up to 15 years in prison
and he's pled guilty
remember he was arrested in illinois but
he pled guilty actually by
zoom and that was in connection to
charges in the new york case
involving obviously r kelly you know the
attorney
has said here that the prosecution is
really going to
push because this was really a shock to
the conscience and i totally agree with
that when you have anybody who's trying
to bribe
a witness it undermines the criminal
justice system
and i think they should and i think they
will pursue this to the fullest extent
of the law
now anna when it comes to the witness
tampering could a jury in the rape case
also hear that he tried to silence the
witness or will that be a completely and
separate case
well i think if there's anything to tie
him to
to this individual who just who just
took a plea
i think if there's anything to tie r
kelly back to that person making the
bribes and absolutely under a theory of
consciousness of guilt
so it's not the case that your crime
stops when
when you're when the actual act that
you're charged with stops a jury is
allowed to look at
how you reacted after the fact and
determine
are you acting like a guilty person are
you acting like you have
consciousness of guilt and that can
include did you flee a scene did you
have a false alibi did you hide or
destroy evidence
in fact i always counsel my clients you
know if you know the police are looking
for you
turn yourself in hire an attorney
don't get in a car chase because you
don't want to create anything that looks
like consciousness of guilt i think
attempting to bribe a witness uh is
clearly consciousness of guilt yeah
there's a strong chance is coming into
the new case i
agree with you there anna when we come
back a rape suspect allegedly hires
hitman to take out his accusers
but they apparently kill the wrong
people the three suspects now behind
bars
after the break
professors at top american universities
are facing criminal charges
accused of work for foreign governments
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross digs into how millions of dollars
could have gone unreported thanks brian
coming up this week on brian ross
investigates
the china initiative a look at the
highly controversial effort begun by the
trump administration
to crack down on supposed chinese
espionage in this country
with a focus on american scientists and
professors
at least 10 american professors from
some of the best universities in the
country have been arrested
and charged with taking secret payments
from china
it has become much too commonplace that
the ruling
communist party of china thinks it can
conduct illegal activity
and bend people here in the united
states to its will
in order to try and surpass our country
as the world's leading superpower
this is the justice department's effort
to really try to root out
uh contacts that have been in place or
something in
in combination with the fbi to really
kind of get their arms around
to the extent to which china is
collecting in the u.s either for
espionage purposes or just state
collection
but now there's a pushback from the
academics of this world we'll talk about
it
this week i'm brian ross investigates
brian
thanks bro we'll be sure to check that
out when we can in other news
louisiana police say three men are
facing charges
after a murder for hire plot ended with
the deaths of two
unintended targets beau colmer was
arrested last may for third degree rape
of his niece
investigators believe colmer hired two
hitmen his friends
andrew escon and dalvin wilson to kill
the rape accuser so she couldn't testify
against him
but when the men allegedly went to the
victim's house on january 16th
her mother and komir's sister brittany
comey said she was her and was shot
neighbor hope nelton tried to fight off
the suspects and was shot as well
here's how police say they carried out
the plot
both andrew and dalvin traveled to
monavie to develop surveillance under
residence sometimes after july
or before november on november 2020
andrew and dalvin returned to montague
to commit the homicide using
a family member's vehicle but it was a
failed attempt
on january 13th dalvin used abram's
truck
to commit the murder shooter
asking for the rape victim by name
and brittany cormier tell the shooter
that she's directly
accepting her faith to save the life of
an imagination
pope nederson actually struggled with
issues
and was shot finding him all andrew
lescon
and dalvin wilson bolted investor
involvement in this incident
all right anna and terry are here one
last time to break down this murder for
hire plot
anna i want you to imagine you're picked
up cormier's case at arraignment
what are the two worst facts you'll have
to face at trial as his lawyer
well this this uh press conference just
took place yesterday so there really
aren't a lot of facts out there but one
thing i do know
is that there were living witnesses to
the incident there were there are
um at least voice and i think you know
facial witnesses to the killing of these
two women i've read that there were
there were three witnesses and
unfortunately i think your two worst
facts are the two of those witnesses
were children they were children who
were hidden in a closet but
heard what happened depending on the age
of those children
they may not be qualified to testify in
a court but
uh boy that's a bad fact that you have
children hiding who who heard what
happened
you know that's that's going to be
really pulling on the heartstrings of
any jury that might see this case
and just and just the fact that you have
you know someone who can identify these
people
absolutely and terry do you think the
murder for hire
of a rape victim will have an impact on
the willingness of other rape victims to
testify
absolutely it's really going to have a
very chilling effect brian on anyone
who's a rape victim first of all
you have to come up and testify and it's
a very difficult sensitive subject to
discuss
but the fact that you know that there
was a plot against this individual
to be killed is going to definitely
prevent you from wanting to come and
testify
and frankly it's an assault on the
criminal justice system and the d.a said
that he might just even consider the
death penalty so he considers it
seriously as well
absolutely the death penalty being on
the table shows a prosecutor who might
be pushing
all the way anna terry thank you for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you